[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez-vous vous avez un léger
problème de vue pas grand chose juste il
vous manque de dixièmes dans chaque œil
ce problème de vue il ne vous empêche en
rien de servir correctement votre café
le matin de regarder un match à la télé
ou encore de lire l'heure sur une
horloge
mais voilà c'est vrai que parfois il
rend les choses un peu plus lointaines
un peu plus flou un peu moins clair
mais vous utilisez des lunettes tout
simplement sauf pour nager la même
passion c'est votre truc depuis tout
petit vous adorez le sport et c'est ce
sport que vous avez choisi
vous avez un rêve vous voulez participer
à une compétition internationale et
représenter la France
donc tous les jours vous allez à la
piscine et tous les jours vous vous
entraînez dur dur dur votre entraîneur
croit énormément en vous il sait que
vous avez un potentiel et c'est que vous
êtes capable de faire des grandes choses
vos camarades vous décrivent comme
quelqu'un de très combatif toujours prêt
à faire plus
après de nombreuses heures
d'entraînement vous l'avez devant vous
cette sélection aux championnats du
monde
vous vous dites maintenant que je suis
autant y aller jusqu'au bout et faire un
résultat
on est le matin de la compétition
vous regardez l'heure il est 9h30 vous
servez votre café il y a un match au
loin à la télé il reste trois heures
avant la course
vous vous déplacez sur le lieu
d'entraînement et de la compétition
votre entraîneur vous envoie un dernier
message il reste deux heures avant la
course
puis
vous débutez votre échauffement
vous repensez à tous ces sacrifices tous
ces moments de travail tous ces heures
dans l'eau
il reste une heure
enfin les derniers préparatifs
vous appréciez vous approchez du blog
vous êtes prêts à monter sur le plot
et là quelqu'un vous interpelle un
arbitre
il vous dit que votre dossier médical
n'est pas à jour et que vous pouvez pas
courir vous pourrez pas faire la
compétition
on est d'accord cette histoire est
absurde
je m'appelle Heidi Gauguin j'ai 18 ans
je suis née sans avant bras gauche une
agénésie du bras je pratique le cyclisme
depuis l'âge de mes 11 ans d'abord chez
les valides puis en handisport
en juillet 2022 j'ai été sélectionné
pour la première fois de ma vie en
équipe de France avec les valides pour
discuter un championnat d'Europe de
contre-la-montre alors que je
m'apprêtais à partir un arbitre vient me
voir et me signale que je pourrais pas
faire partie du classement
donc maintenant
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un vote
si demain
Usain Bolt avait un accident et perdait
son bras gauche qui parmi vous dans la
salle l'exclurait complètement des
compétitions valides et lui demanderait
de faire exclusivement du sport
je vous propose de voter qui parmi vous
lui dirait écoute chaîne maintenant tu
restes en handisport et tu fais plus de
valides
d'accord donc maintenant j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut
toujours séparer les valides des
handisports pourquoi est-ce que les
personnes qui ont un handicap qui ont
une différence doivent toujours être
séparés et ne peuvent pas s'exprimer
je pense qu'on définit trop facilement
les gens avec leurs différences je sais
tout faire comme vous
mis à part un truc je sais pas faire de
corde à sauter j'arrive pas mais
personne ne me présentera comme ça voici
Heidi qui sait pas faire de corde à
sauter personne ne dira ça en fait ce
que vous allez retenir de moi c'est mon
absence de bras mais pourquoi est-ce que
vous vous concentrez sur quelque chose
qui n'existe même pas ce bras il est pas
là depuis 18 ans il sera pas là les 18
prochaines années non plus donc pourquoi
est-ce que vous allez retenir de moi du
vide
je pense que je peux me servir de ma
différence pour faire une force et une
opportunité j'ai tellement plus à offrir
et j'ai un rêve mon rêve est de
participer et de remporter une médaille
aux Jeux olympiques et aux Jeux
paralympiques la même année Los Angeles
2028 2032 2036 je ne sais pas je sais
qu'il y a beaucoup de travail à faire et
voici mon rêve donc maintenant je vous
propose de reprendre l'histoire du début
vous êtes toujours nageur
vous avez toujours une différence
puisque vous manque toujours de dixième
dans chaque œil
mais votre plus grande différence en
fait c'est pas ça votre différence c'est
que vous y croyez et vous croyez en vous
donc le week-end qui suit vous
réinscrivez à une compétition
vous remontez sur le plan
vous nagez
et vous savez quoi cette compétition
vous la gagnez
merci
[Musique]